there are 7.8 billion people living in a
world in the grips of the pandemic
and vaccines for only 650 million of
them produced and distributed by only a
handful of large pharmaceutical
companies and so far
distributed mostly to rich countries of
the world
to change that countries like india and
south africa are urging the world trade
organization
to introduce a temporary patent waiver
for producing covid19 vaccines
the idea is to allow other countries to
make their own versions of vaccines and
scale up production
something they say is essential to win
the race against time with a mutating
virus
but so far without success the uk
us and the eu are among those blocking
the waiver
and major pharma companies are opposing
it too so
why won't they budge are we prolonging
the pandemic because pharma companies
want the big bucks
or is it more complicated five major
covit 19 vaccine producers account for
over 90 percent of all vaccines produced
globally
it's projected companies will scale up
massively by the end of 2021
but proponents of the waiver say
production needs to happen
faster especially in light of boosters
or new vaccines we may need to tackle a
mutating virus
you know patents were never supposed to
be implemented during emergencies like a
pandemic
it says so explicitly even in the trips
agreement
the purpose of this waiver is to make
sure that countries everywhere can
increase production and generate enough
supply to meet the demand that is
increasing so rapidly
over 100 nations led by india and south
africa
are asking the wto for a temporary
suspension of certain patent rules
enshrined in the so-called trips
agreement short for trade related
aspects of intellectual property rights
to put it simply supporters say a patent
waiver would help overcome certain legal
barriers
preventing them from producing their own
vaccines
they also argue the waiver could be a
first step towards distributing vaccines
more equally
for now over 80 percent of all vaccines
have gone into the arms of people in
rich and middle-income countries
and ngos estimate that 9 in 10 people in
70 countries
won't receive a job this year in fact
many predict that most poor countries
will not achieve mass vaccination
until 2024. supporters of the waiver
also argue more
manufacturers in more countries could
drive prices down
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson have
vowed to provide vaccines on a
non-profit basis during the pandemic
but moderner and pfizer have not pfizer
is charging 39
in the us and around 37 in the eu for
two jabs
prices that are set to rise even further
in 2022
and which are essentially unpayable for
poorer countries
nobody's saying that they shouldn't make
any profits from that from the
pandemic and in fact they're making the
companies are making
lots of money these will be like among
the biggest selling products in the
world for anything
these are massive amounts of money if
you open up the licensing so that more
people can use the intellectual property
it doesn't mean that you don't get
anything it just means that you just
don't have a monopoly the monopoly is
inappropriate and pandemic one
government that signaled it may rethink
its opposition to the waiver
is the biden administration outside
pressure on the us has been mounting
over 170 former heads of state and nobel
laureates
as well as a series of u.s lawmakers and
global organizations have called on the
u.s government to reverse its veto
it's the rich country governments that
have been opposing the trip
waiver in the wto if the u.s
administration and president biden agree
to stop opposing it that's a huge step
forward and i do believe it would
persuade a number of other countries
so stop opposing the waiver but
opposition to the idea of a waiver
remains strong
the eu uk japan and brazil are among
those blocking it
the pharma and intellectual property
lobby are opposed to it too
and some say a waiver is unnecessary
there's
been absolutely no credible evidence
that intellectual property rights
have constituted a barrier to
development of the needed
coven-19 vaccines therapeutics and
diagnostics opponents to the proposal
say that waiving intellectual property
rights could kill innovation
and that if innovation is not rewarded
it could discourage investors and
companies from spending money on such
research in the future
for them voluntary licenses are the way
to go and they say that they've already
been granted to manufacturers fulfilling
requirements
many also say the waiver wouldn't lead
to more vaccine doses
one of the arguments the world is
already working at maximum speed
the manufacturing capacity that the
world
can put to this problem is being fully
utilized now
the central challenge is manufacturing
at scale
and it just takes time
it takes 60 to 110 days to produce a
single
batch of copic 19 vaccines
countries like bangladesh and canada on
the other hand have claimed they do have
production capacity
it's just not being used all sides agree
that a patent waiver would not be a
silver bullet
the production and distribution of covit
19 vaccines
involves many challenges from the
complexity of supply chains
to shortages of raw materials and the
need to meet high production standards
a central issue the backers of the
waiver say therefore
is for companies to share their know-how
and for governments to increase pressure
on them to do so
the waiver is one part of a broader
package that we definitely have to have
but we must have the transfer of
technology and we must have global
efforts to increase the supply of
essential raw materials
to make these drugs and vaccines the who
has already created a covit 19
technology access pool
or ctap designed to do just that share
vaccine technology
skills and know-how with prominent
supporters like u.s chief medical
advisor anthony fauci
yes yes yes so far
none of the major pharmaceutical
companies producing vaccines have signed
up